[Música]
que tienen en común un rebozo y una
palapa
antes de revelarles la respuesta les
invito a que pensemos juntos en un
término que se ha vuelto muy familiar en
nuestra habla cotidiana muy común me
refiero a la globalización
si yo les pido que piensen en algo que
les remita a la globalización
posiblemente podrán pensar en un
teléfono celular que se ha convertido en
justamente un símbolo de esa conexión
global que nos dan las tecnologías de la
información algunos de ustedes tal vez
podrá pensar en una cadena de
hamburguesas
el caso es que a solemos considerar a la
globalización como un fenómeno reciente
y que está más ligado a la economía que
a la cultura
la palabra clave de la globalización es
conexión una conexión a un nivel muy
grande entre continentes entre regiones
y países sin embargo esa conexión
también existe a nivel de los individuos
a nivel personal como cuando algunos de
ustedes tal vez juegan a sesiones de
videojuegos con contrincantes o con
compañeros que están en otros países no
es verdad
lo que me gustaría es que reflexionarán
conmigo de que a posiblemente no están
tan ciertos no saben tanto de que la
globalización es un proceso bastante que
podemos remitir a muchos años atrás y
que hay no es méxico este país ha tenido
un papel fundamental
en este proceso
mi intención es que juntos podamos
analizar la capacidad de transformación
las culturas que tiene justamente la
globalización la globalización perdón
justo a partir de las conexiones entre
individuos si conexiones de gustos de
ideas o de conocimientos
para responder a mi pregunta si hay un
tipo de rebozos que son que tienen unas
manchitas blancas sí que son muy
populares en general este tipo de
rebozos tienen en común con las palapas
que su origen es asiático
más precisamente del sudeste asiático de
filipinas y sus alrededores
seguramente recordarán en sus clases de
historia que en méxico durante el
periodo virreinal era llamado la nueva
españa
tal vez podrán también recordar que las
filipinas formaban parte de ese
virreinato
hay autores que afirman que a partir de
esa relación entre méxico y filipinas se
dio la primera globalización y esto
ocurrió hace ya casi 500 años es decir
medio milenio
porque se dio es porque se nombra a esa
relación como una primera globalización
pues porque a través a partir de esa
relación se concretaron una serie de
intercambios sí y de relaciones
comerciales que afectaron a todos los
continentes en manila la capital de
filipinas se embarcaban en ese gran
cargamento de piezas de objetos que no
sólo venían de el archipiélago nuevo
hispano sino venían de china de japón de
la india de malasia e indonesia
este precioso cargamento era embarcado
en un galeón que para la época era el
barco más grande que existía y hacía una
travesía que podría durar que podía
durar meses hasta llegar a donde a
acapulco en las costas del sur de méxico
en acapulco era desembarcado y a su vez
transportado a lomo de mula a las
grandes ciudades como méxico o
guadalajara pero también llegaba a
pequeñas villas e incluso a comunidades
en las simas telas de sedas preciosas o
de algodones
sí que estaban bastante de moda por
cierto durante la época eran traídas y
eran muy apetecidas aquí junto a ellas
venían marfil les venían lacas
porcelanas pero también venían las
especias como el clavo la canela o la
pimienta que se integraron muy bien a
nuestro paladar no es cierto
la plata mexicana que salía justamente
de nuestras minas era a su vez enmarcada
en el bueno en el mismo galeón para
hacer el recorrido de regreso y pagar
por esas mercaderías que venían para acá
esa plata era muy apetecida también en
toda asia
acompañando ese cargamento iban personas
por supuesto que muchas de ellas se
quedaron
en el archipiélago se adaptaron y de
hecho compartieron no nada más sus
gustos y conocimientos sino sus
prácticas es decir que hay huella de la
cultura mexicana que todavía sigue viva
en la que lucen aquellos lugares
la globalización es un proceso histórico
y cultural
por lo tanto nos habla de conexiones
esto son mucho más complejas que
solamente relaciones económicas
muchos científicos entre historiadores
lingüistas pero también investigadores
del genoma humano han investigado y han
comprobado que durante ese proceso que
duró varios cientos de años llegaron a
nuestras costas miles de personas de
todos los confines de asia sí y que al
llegar aquí se adaptaron
y llegaron nada más no nada más con su
fuerza de trabajo
su bagaje cultural dejó huella
esos que ahora llamaríamos migrantes
y con sus gustos con sus modos de hacer
con sus conocimientos aportaron una gran
cantidad de elementos a nuestra cultura
que ahora pensamos que son completamente
nuestros como es la sofisticada técnica
de tinción así que estos rebosos tienen
esos puntitos de los que les hablo y que
implican una gran cantidad de
conocimientos y procedimientos técnicos
que vino de asia hacia méxico
no quiero decir que los rebozos vienen
de asia lo que quiero decir es que hay
técnicas y conocimientos que se
empezaron a aplicar aquí a partir de ese
proceso del que les estoy hablando
este no es un fenómeno exclusivo
ni mucho menos es parte del proceso de
la diversidad cultural que ocurre en
todas las regiones también en
hispanoamérica porque podría ser
distinto
el paliacate por ejemplo que es tan
popular cuyo origen está en la india o
tal vez el mantón de manila que es una
prenda tan tradicional del sur de españa
es un regalo también de las filipinas y
con esos ejemplos puedo añadir muchos
otros sí el comer mango con chile o con
limón el a las cocadas o los dulces de
tamarindo por dar sólo algunos ejemplos
las peleas de gallos por cierto quiere
decir que en toda hispanoamérica tenemos
huellas tenemos pruebas de que esas
tradiciones que son que consideramos que
son completamente locales si sus raíces
vienen de mucho más de regiones mucho
más lejanas
para concluir me gustaría dejar un par
de ideas
muchos investigadores han hablado del
mestizaje y de la diversidad cultural
como algo solo ligado a la imposición
colonial hispánica
sí pero yo quisiera que pudiéramos verlo
también como algo que ocurrió entre
personas entre individuos sin jerarquías
sí entre marineros
agricultores vendedores ambulantes o
tejedoras
la cultura es un artefacto humano
producto de miles de interacciones en
miles durante miles de años de tal
manera que sostener que hay pureza
cultural o pureza genética no tiene
fundamento científico ni histórico
la diversidad cultural es garantía de la
expresividad humana
y no una amenaza a nuestra identidad
de tal manera que yo les invito a que
cual si fuera un rebozo abracemos la
diversidad cultural